[Musique]
dans un monde en perpétuel évolution où
les progrès en matière de technologie
sont constants l'innovation est une
nécessité absolue un enjeu d'autant plus
crucial pour nos armées qu'il
conditionne notre autonomie et notre
supériorité stratégique
la loi de programmation militaire
2019-2025 prévoit d'augmenter de 25%,
les critiques consacrés à l'innovation
pour atteindre un milliard d'euros en
laser arme électromagnétique
technologique quantique l'armée de
demain se construit aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais à côté de ces grands programmes
c'est au quotidien que le personnel des
armées invente des solutions aux
problèmes vécues sur le terrain
rencontre avec les géo trouvent tous des
armées
[Musique]
tous ces militaires et civils rassemblés
à Balard au printemps dernier au cœur du
ministère des armées sont venus
présenter leur innovation
donc voici une protection thermique pour
pose pilote de Rafale c'est un drone
spécifiquement pensé et dédié à
l'investigation sur scène de crime j'ai
développé un module de sport qui peut
être projeté pour les soldats sur le
terrain
d'un pare-soleil pour avion rafale à une
salle de sport en kit en passant par une
bouteille d'oxygène de poche nous ne
sommes pas au concours Lépine mais au
prix de l'audace
tous les deux ans il met en lumière et
récompense l'innovation participative au
sein de l'armée et de la gendarmerie
nationale des projets développés par des
passionnés qui n'ont qu'une idée en tête
améliorer leur travail au quotidien nous
devions développer un drone
qui ne brasse pas d'air et ne tombe pas
ce colonel de l'Institut de recherche
criminelle de la gendarmerie nationale
une seule obsession pénétrée sur une
scène de crime sans la polluer
finalement le drone est passé en
flottabilité positive c'est à dire qu'il
a tendance à monter et plutôt que dans
les drones traditionnels des hélices qui
tournent pour le faire monter mais nous
là on cherche à le faire descendre des
Falcons qu'est ce qui se passe ce
brassage d'air ne se fait pas vers le
bas mais vers le haut et des facto aussi
je préserve les différentes traces
d'intérêt criminelistique nécessaire à
la résolution de la fête criminelle
certaines innovations font appel aux
dernières technologies telles que
l'impression 3D ou les mini drônes alors
que d'autres permettent de faire des
économies pour une bouchée de pain comme
avec cette protection thermique ma
réflexion est assez simple c'est
pourquoi il existe ce type de système
pour nos véhicules et pas pour nos
avions l'équipement vaut 250 000 euros à
peu près donc grâce à une une protection
thermique d'une valeur de moins de 1000
euros on arrive à protéger un vol des
équipements et tout ce qui va avec
l'innovation participative propose bien
souvent une solution simple à des
problèmes du quotidien mais elle prend
parfois une dimension stratégique
il suffit maintenant de choisir les
différents cas et on voit les domaines
qui évoluent et qui arrivent
au bon élément notre innovation
s'appelle Zéphir h elle a pour but
l'optimisation opérationnelle du couple
hélicoptère bâtiment en gros le but
c'est de permettre la mise en oeuvre des
hélicoptères dans le plus grand champ
possible de vent et de mouvement de
plateforme avec cette innovation
l'ambition est simple prendre l'avantage
sur l'ennemi
mettre en oeuvre en hélicoptère c'est
mettre en oeuvre un système d'armes se
mettre en oeuvre des capteurs optiques
des capteurs sonars et si on peut les
mettre en œuvre dans des conditions où
notre ennemi ne peut pas le mettre en
oeuvre on a déjà un avantage
cette diversité des projets d'innovation
participative est à l'image des femmes
et hommes du ministère des armées
une richesse reconnue par sa ministre
Florence Parly
insister sur cette innovation
participative qui vient
du terrain des hommes et des femmes du
ministère des armées qui chacun mettent
leurs compétences leur expertise leur
créativité au service de l'excellence et
qui consacre du temps de l'énergie
souvent en plus de tout ce qu'ils ont à
faire et qui bénéficie de
désencouragements de leur hiérarchie
pour aller au bout de leur idée et aller
au bout de leurs projets
il s'agit de définir h car avant d'être
mise en avant et récompensé le capitaine
de corvette Jean-Baptiste et le
lieutenant de vaisseau Nicolas ont
fourni un travail de longue haleine
et pour mieux le comprendre direction la
base aéronautique de Hyères
c'est ici que nous retrouvons l'un de
ces deux innovateurs
donc on va commencer le briefing
aujourd'hui on fait un vol
d'expérimentation sur la Provence en
panthère
au programme aujourd'hui un vol en
hélicoptère dans le cadre du projet
Zéphir h
l'objectif récolter un maximum
d'informations lors des phases
d'approntage sur une frégate
multimissions afin d'étoffer sa base de
données
le but ça va être d'aller vérifier qu'on
peut affronter dans des conditions qui
ont pas encore été validées qu'on va
pouvoir capter des données
quantitatives et puis et puis moi je
décrirai également tous les attentats je
trouve pour vérifier que c'est faisable
par par un pilote lambda
pour réussir sa mission Nicolas va
pouvoir utiliser tous les capteurs
installés dans cette hélicoptère
panthère
[Musique]
la collecte et la vérification des
données se fait à l'arrière c'est le
travail du capitaine de frégate Germain
après un vol d'une vingtaine de minutes
au-dessus de la Méditerranée la frégate
Provence se profile à l'horizon
l'expérimentation peut commencer
[Musique]
on est posé à fond
donc il y a pas de souci
turbulences je mets un deux un deux on a
eu deux longueurs de pont on a eu les
retours sûrement des fumées de du
bâtiment
[Musique]
50 60 15
la voyante
paramètres pression température tout est
correctisément devait sceaux et son
équipage ont récolté toutes les données
nécessaires à leur expérimentation du
jour des données jusqu'ici inédites car
chaque avantage est différent
il y a tellement de paramètres qui
rentrent en compte dans un avantage il y
a la pression la température du jour le
niveau de la mer la fréquence de la
houle il y a tellement de choses qui
rentrent en compte que qu'en fait aucun
avantage n'est pareil même les
plateformes de chacun est rentré en
compte dans ce genre d'activités qui
sont pour lesquelles il faut être très
concentré et très précis
de retour sur la terre ferme il faut
désormais analyser toutes les données
collectées durant le vol
Nicolas cherche à créer des diagrammes
d'appontage traduction un document de
référence qui sert de boussole lors de
cette phase délicate un diagramme
d'appontage c'est un peu une rose des
ventes c'est c'est une force et une
direction de vent qu'on valide ou contre
valide pas c'est ni plus ni moins une
carte d'autorisation de venir se poser
chaque hélicoptère et chaque bâtiment de
surface fonctionne en couple pour chacun
de ces couples il n'y a qu'un nombre
limité de diagramme d'apontage
aujourd'hui l'ensemble de cette
documentation n'existe que sous format
papier et ne représente que 300 pages
avec Zéphir h le capitaine Nicolas en a
déjà généré plus de 8000 c'est autant de
possibilités en plus pour déployer nos
hélicoptères ça le premier effet de
pouvoir multiplier le nombre de cas et
donc d'augmenter les capacités
opérationnelles des couples hélicoptères
bâtiments et le et la deuxième c'est
c'est d'augmenter la sécurité parce que
le logiciel est ni plus ni moins un
moteur de recherche si on lui donne les
bonnes informations d'entrée il nous
donnera la bonne réponse une innovation
qui donnerait à chacun de ces couples
bâtiments hélicoptère la possibilité
d'être déployée plus facilement et dans
des conditions plus variées hélicoptère
est un système d'armes du bâtiment donc
c'est de pouvoir le mettre en oeuvre
dans les le maximum de conditions
possibles pour prendre le dessus sur le
théâtre voilà donc le but c'est vraiment
de leur donner le maximum de capacités
tout en restant
dans une enveloppe de sécurité simple
au-delà de tous ces enjeux opérationnels
le projet Zéphyr h représente aussi pour
Nicolas ainsi que son co-créateur
l'occasion d'apporter leur pierre à
l'édifice ce qui est vraiment bien c'est
quand cette pierre-là est remarquée et
va potentiellement je l'espère
être déployé au sein de l'institution
dans laquelle on travaille depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'années
Zéphir h c'est déjà plus de deux ans de
travail personnel pour ses innovateurs
qui ne comptent pas s'arrêter en si bon
chemin
[Musique]
un travail rendu possible en partie
grâce au soutien de l'agence innovation
de défense et de sa cellule innovation
participative
pour son directeur la variété des
profils qui composent le ministère des
armées est une richesse qu'il convient
de mettre en avant
désormais c'est un réservoir de talent
et donc quand vous avez un personnel qui
innove dans n'importe quel domaine ça
signifie qu'on n'est pas très loin d'une
solution opérationnelle rapide à un
problème qui est un problème pragnant
l'innovation participative répond à des
problèmes concrets elle permet aussi de
réaffirmer la culture de l'engagement et
du dépassement au sein de nos forces
l'innovation participative c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui nécessite un
engagement permanent puisque
effectivement les officiers
sous-officiers militaires durant aussi
villes vont travailler le soir le
week-end sur leurs vacances mais vont
également acculturer leurs camarades à
cette prise de risque et je pense que ce
symbolique de la prise de risque qui est
très différente de celle qui est prise
en opération mais une prise de risque
personnel et quelque chose qui doit être
encouragé qui doit être effectivement
partagé et comme le disait la ministre
des Armées France par lit une armée qui
innove c'est une armée qui ne dépose pas
les armes
et aujourd'hui on voit si deux qui ne
sont pas prêts à les déposer justement
l'adjudant-chef Pascal du 13e bataillon
de chasseurs alpins et l'adjudant chef
Michaël du 93e régiment d'artillerie de
montagne sont ici pour présenter leur
idée d'innovation
donc ce projet c'est bien une lunette de
tir à faible grossissement et à
grossissement variable qui va de 1
jusqu'à 8 à engager l'ennemi autour de
la table un jury composé d'experts en
charge d'examiner la pertinence de leurs
projets
intellectuelles possibilités
d'exploitation des problématiques
parfois nouvelles pour des innovateurs
et pour lesquels la cellule innovation
participative peut proposer un soutien
financier et logistique
notre rôle consiste fondamentalement à
encadrer la démarche de l'innovateur
pour l'aider en mettant en oeuvre
certains leviers en évitant certains
écueils pour l'aider à ce que le projet
aboutisse
à la clé un financement qui peut grimper
jusqu'à 100 000 euros et permettre le
bon développement d'un projet
de quelque chose d'efficace mais pour
l'adjudant chef Pascal il s'agit avant
tout de transmettre un savoir-faire
spécifique à qui tout au long de sa
carrière
c'est l'ensemble de ces savoir-faire
qu'on souhaite
amener on est quasiment tous en fin de
carrière et on souhaite un petit peu
transmettre notre notre savoir notre
expertise au futur génération et essayer
d'apporter notre contribution à la météo
par un produit qui est qui à mon sens
innovant au niveau du latitude une
ambition doublée d'une touche toute
personnelle mon garçon va s'engager dans
l'armée terre et si je pouvais
transmettre quelque chose à mon garçon
ce serait quelque chose d'extraordinaire
et ce serait ça justement entre autres
pour pouvoir donner un saint
voilà même si l'adjudant chef Pascal est
convaincu du bien fondé de son projet il
devra attendre quelques semaines pour
savoir si son idée est retenue au total
en 2020 ce sont près de 90 projets qui
ont été financés et accompagnés par la
cellule innovation participative
des projets qui permettent à leur
innovateur de se dépasser et de se
révéler c'est le cas du projet vanitaque
porté depuis deux ans par
l'adjudant-christel de la section
technique de l'armée de terre
c'est une valise qui va permettre de
tester les câbles directement voir si
son correct ou pas vous voyez ici je
teste un câble Perk 4G qui va jusqu'à un
ordinateur et la valise m'indique que le
câble est correct donc je sais un câble
que je vais pouvoir utiliser sans
problème et sans me soucier du fait que
ça ne fonctionne pas une fois que
j'aurai initialisé tout mon système
une valise de diagnostic électronique
pour véhicules que Christelle a pensé à
décliner en plusieurs versions dont une
de poche afin de pouvoir effectuer des
tests à tout moment donc là un boîtier
d'alimentation pour le père 4G donc
c'est bien elle est venue de part mon
travail mon expérience de
sous-officiaire radio mais aussi de par
toutes les discussions que j'ai pu avoir
avec des collègues qui travaillaient
dans des ateliers de transmission donc
au niveau des des régiments ou
finalement on n'avait pas on n'avait pas
d'outils de test de câbles donc eux
m'ont présenté ce qu'ils avaient
fabriqué maison entre guillemets et du
coup là l'idée a émergé d'avoir un outil
de test à mettre en oeuvre très
facilement du coup VANITA que l'idée de
VANITA Québec
une idée en apparence toute simple mais
qui va changer le quotidien de bon
nombre de techniciens
car aujourd'hui si les véhicules
déployés en opération sont bardées de
câbles et d'informatique en cas de panne
il faut bien souvent les immobiliser en
atelier pendant plusieurs jours
de diagnostic de câble au sein des
véhicules et on apporte un testeur pour
les personnels donc ça va gagner en
rapidité pour les diagnostics au lieu de
passer
de longs moments sur des recherches de
panne ici on va pouvoir directement
dédouaner le câblage du véhicule un gain
de temps et de moyens précieux sur les
théâtres d'opérations mais ce projet a
aussi été l'occasion pour Christelle de
s'affirmer au sein de l'armée
des nouveaux câbles et nouveaux une
évolution à laquelle a assisté son
supérieur durant les deux dernières
années
des ateliers l'évolution de la dune en
Christelle s'est faite effectivement en
plusieurs étapes avec au tout début une
certaine phase de doute en se demandant
si effectivement son projet était
intéressant si il a les réellement
apporter quelque chose et ensuite à
mesure que que le projet commençait à
grandir et ben elle a été amenée à faire
des présentations de plus en plus
souvent à des autorités de plus en plus
importantes au sein de notre institution
ce qui lui a permis également de prendre
confiance en elle et en l'intérêt de son
projet et à l'heure actuelle elle est
elle est pleinement satisfaite et de ce
qu'elle va apporter aux forces car pour
vanitaque le succès est au rendez-vous
une vingtaine de valises ont déjà été
commandées et vont bientôt venir équiper
les régiments et ce n'est qu'un début
ici donc à ton premier véhicule ici on
va faire un deuxième véhicule ici avec
deux pdt aussi une réussite qui vient
récompenser un travail de longue haleine
porter un projet innovation c'est
beaucoup de travail personnels mais je
m'attendais pas à arriver jusqu'à un
niveau de travail personnel niveau
juridique niveau
c'est vrai que ce sont des choses qui
nous dépassent un peu nous en tant
qu'innovateur parce que nous on voit le
besoin en tant que militaire on voit pas
cet aspect cet aspect administratif qui
est une grosse grosse partie de
l'innovation d'ailleurs des domaines
dont elle n'avait pas idée avant de se
lancer dans cette aventure mais pour
elle le jeu en vaut la chandelle c'est
un enrichissement personnel d'avoir
eu
cette idée et puis sortir à quelque
chose de physique de concret au final
sur sur juste une idée de départ c'est
un je trouve que c'est un enrichissant
personnellement c'est c'est une
plus-value énorme et je le conseille
d'ailleurs à tout le monde si vous avez
des idées pour aider les combattants
il faut il faut vraiment sauter le pas
sautez le pas c'est exactement ce qu'a
fait Albin
ce chercheur du service de santé des
armées nous a donné rendez-vous en
Camargue
chevaux flamants roses et autres
volatiles ont fait la renommée de cette
belle région
[Musique]
qui vous intéressent alors non pas du
tout aujourd'hui on a un Camargue c'est
une région connue pour les oiseaux les
chevaux et les taureaux mais aujourd'hui
c'est les moustiques qu'on parchassés et
particulièrement les virus qui
transmettent
accompagné par Frédéric de l'Entente
interdépartementale de la des
moustication du littoral méditerranéen
Albin est venu relever les pièges posées
il y a quelques jours
des pièges classiques que l'on retrouve
dans le commerce sauf calebin y a ajouté
son innovation
on a ajouté un dispositif imprimé 3D qui
permet de les garder en vie pendant
plusieurs jours voici comment il à quoi
il ressemble c'est un cylindre qui est
composé de plusieurs parties il y a
un haut un bas qui s'emboîte à
l'intérieur il est transpercé par un par
un autre cylindre qui permet de garder
un flux et garder une aspiration en haut
du piège le moustique va être aspiré
attiré par le CO2 aspirer il va rentrer
dans le système et à l'intérieur il aura
le gîte et le couvert et un coin
toilette
vous ne rêvez pas Albin a bel et bien
créé un hôtel à moustique non pas pour
le confort de ce petit arthropode mais
plutôt pour faire avancer la science
ce qui l'intéresse ce sont avant tout
les excréments que déposent ces hôtes au
fond du dispositif
on a bien évidence en laboratoire
c'était lors de mon postdoc à l'Institut
Pasteur que des moustiques qui étaient
infectés pouvaient sécréter du virus via
leur excrétion et en les quantités qui
sont bien supérieures que dans la salive
ce qui améliore les soldes de détection
pour pour une application de terrain en
surveillance
une méthode novatrice qui a permis l'an
dernier et en quelques semaines à peine
d'attester la présence en Camargue d'une
souche de la fièvre du Nil ou westnail
un virus découvert en Ouganda en 1937 et
la première fois qu'elle a été décrit un
Camargue c'est dans les années 60 il y a
eu des épidémie de chevaux et le virus a
été identifié sur des prélèvements de
chevaux et aussi dans un moustique mais
depuis 1964 il y a eu des cas
répertoriés humains et de chevaux mais
jamais personne n'a mis en évidence des
virus dans les moustiques autre avantage
de la méthode d'Albin ces échantillons
peuvent être conservés à température
ambiante et voyager par courrier postal
pour être analysé
c'est ici dans une unité de l'Institut
de recherche biomédicale des armées
situées dans les locaux de l'iachu de
Marseille Calba menzset travaux grâce à
son innovation la recherche sur les
épidémies sera moins longue et moins
coûteuse
lors d'une épidémie la prévalence de
moustiques qui sont infectés sur le
terrain et extrêmement faible et de
l'ordre de 1 pour 1000 à peu près donc
il faut processer 1000 moustiques pour
réussir à en avoir un ça prend beaucoup
de temps et beaucoup d'argent ici on
peut aller voir directement s'il y a du
virus le séquence est directement dans
les dans les inscriptions une méthode
d'analyse plus rapide et donc moins cher
mais qui permet surtout de comprendre
plus en détail l'écosystème dans lequel
s'est développé la maladie
ça permet d'améliorer la compréhension
des acteurs qui sont impliqués dans dans
l'émergence de ces virus essayez de
comprendre quels sont les animaux qui
sont impliqués est-ce que la diversité
de ces animaux qui fluctue peut avoir un
impact sur la recrudescence de cas
humains ça on connaît mal et si on
arrive à mieux comprendre ça on peut
essayer de prévenir les futurs
émergences dans la population humaine et
pour nos soldats déployés sur les
théâtres d'opérations cela va permettre
une surveillance accrue de leur
environnement et une meilleure
protection l'an dernier sur le tas
d'opération de Djibouti il y a une
émergence simultanée de deux virus
principes par les moustiques chikungunya
et dingue et de Plasmodium qui causent
le paludisme ce système là peut
permettre de mettre en évidence de façon
très précoce l'émergence de ces de ces
maladies sans avant qu'il y ait les
premiers cas humains donc c'est un gain
de temps et ça permet de pouvoir avant
le démarrage d'une épidémie prendre des
mesures adéquates
salut Mathieu salut à ta lancer une
impression mais le projet d'Albin ne
s'arrête pas là avec son collègue
Mathieu ils ont dessiné ensemble les
plans de leur prototype
grâce à leur logiciel et une imprimante
3D ils peuvent faire évoluer le projet
et l'améliorer
des plans qu'il comptent également
partager au sein de la communauté
scientifique et ainsi permettre à
d'autres dans le monde civil d'en
profiter notre but à nous c'est de le
rendre ouvert on va y mettre l'objet
d'une publication scientifique
prochainement et les plans seront
disponibles sous licence Creative Common
pour que tout le monde puisse l'imprimer
l'adapter et l'utiliser pour faire leur
surveillance là où ils sont un sens du
partage qui pourrait bien faire de cette
innovation participative un succès
international avec en ligne de mire
l'idée de sauver des vies
et si les petits ruisseaux font les
grandes rivières l'innovation
participative irrigue le ministère des
armées depuis de longues années
en 30 ans elle nous a offert de grands
succès tels que ces combinaisons de
pompiers intelligentes et connectées ou
l'invention du plasma lyophilisé
acteur majeur de l'innovation
participative l'armée de l'air n'est pas
en reste avec ce masque high-tech pour
chien parachutiste mais également avec
le projet Corvus un drone né du retour
d'expérience des forces spéciales
capables de décoller à la verticale il
embarque les derniers équipements de
pointe en matière de reconnaissance et
de surveillance un drone facile à
déployer qui présente l'énorme avantage
de pouvoir être réparés sur les théâtres
d'opération
une innovation participative qui fait
aussi la part belle aux créations
d'applications en tout genre ainsi qu'à
des projets de préservation de
l'environnement
[Musique]
des innovations qui témoignent de la
richesse et de la diversité au sein des
forces un atout dont les armées comptent
bien tirer profit le budget alloué à
l'innovation participative sera doublée
d'ici 2022
[Musique]